was an optional skate this morning
for the Canadians so no working on
the power play and morning skate for them
gager cut again couldn't get the shot off
drops for Anderson spinning shooting as the
suddenly hot read Josh Anderson out the M
net cycle down low to vorak bazetta good bump in
front turnover that shot kicked the side Michael
bazetta back in the lineup and nearly able to set
up Mitchell Stevens for the opening strike gabov
can't keep it in as petta scratched the last
four games back in the lineup as y Aria will
take a seat for this one the healthy scratch
and petta good body check to set up that play
already making his presence known as he gets
in on the four check but that whole sequence
started with a great pinch by Kaden ghouly
holding the Blue Line keeping that offensive
zone possession alive ovsky pace and he hits
the side of the pipe as Sosi on the top line
again with Coffield and Suzuki in front wanted
Suzuki good feed by slavkovsky but nobody home
and Arthur COV the other way he'll chip and
chase after it it's exactly what slavkovsky
need to be doing using his body to Shield off
a very good defenseman there in Drew dowy Co
Coffield creating some space he'll bring it in
drops it off gusta Lindstrom WR shot and a good
save T but is try to hustle back Hy to the puck
and f it to Center in comes copar wrist shot and
the first shot handled and eventually a 4-3 win
in overtime very popular in long time Montreal
Canadian Phill Deno R shot by Trevor Moore steered
into the corner 3 seven minutes got in this first
period mat over the line brings it in mat WR
shot in and out of talot as he had some space
glov side but talot able to recover and keep it
out and here is lazat driving in backhand try on
to both stop Rebound in front that hit the pile
of bodies in front strouble was there Drew doy
who's got goals in back-to-back games including
the OT winners starting the play out of his own
Zone he'll turn 34 years of age tomorrow Drew Dy
what a career he's had with LA in California doie
on the bucket Center Hill back pedal watched
by Josh Anderson hals changing behind the play
Dy brings it in he'll feed that left side
as Dy play right in front score on Q drives
play Dy a little early celebration and the Kings
have a one- nothing lead on the road he continues
to do it year after year he starts this play in
the neutral zone and it's a few Montreal players
who converge at the Blue Line and Drew dowy just
follows his play up he's able to bring this Puck
to the net a little deception and look like he
may have banked that one off of Kaden Gully and
Drew dowy getting his lindst racing over takes
the body check keeps on moving poke towards C
telit goes below the goal line du battling with
Suzuki slowski Suzuki good work and they come
with the buck slavoski trying to get it back to
the captain Mikey Anderson hitting Suzuki it's
up for mat mat Rich onot tipped and hit the mask
of tbit and Lindstrom was driving in couldn't get
there Di and it's sent cross ice for runstrom he's
got some space reach shot and a good stop monteo
Lindstrom the other way try to work around CV and
spinning away from traffic is Young Jordan Spence
for lazat he'll shoot it in Jared Anderson DOL in
the healthy scratch tonight for lazat to come back
into the lineup Pearson frees it for Dvorak dorak
over the line tried to get it back to Pearson he
was all Tangled Up s in front Gallagher shot
handled by talat good look Brenan Gallagher
Lindstrom on the puck first for mat around the
boards there's bazetta bazetta freed the back
hand but a turnover larier got space wrist shot
and bailed out mono a good glove as Alex lafier
Brandon Gallagher able to free it Lindstrom from
his own Zone at the Blue Line flips to his space
finds Gallagher Gallagher across weak shot big
rebound as Dvorak put it right on H in at the
line good job by kovas devic keeps the Play
Alive shot up high available Gallagher dug it
free the back hand feed nobody there as droal
picks it up and the LA Kings got away with it
there big difference when you can get through
the neutral zone Montreal's done a nice job
tonight once they've been able to establish
their presence in the offensive zone moving
on this power play for the Montreal Canadians
is Shawn Monahan in the circle suuki delivers
to Coffield Coffield in his office Suzuki cross
a p off the side of the head sovi in the bumper
position that just goes off the post and you
could kind of see the development it's coming
each and every game for this young man it's
coming with his confidence you can see the
confidence growing he's a much different player
when he plays with that confidence goie through
traffic Evans trying to fish it free he will
Anderson had it lost it there's Kopitar for
kempe Adrien Kee a little bit of speed through
Cent Quinton Byfield driving into the 4 in score
beautiful goal Quinton Byfield his seven
of the season it's a beauty and it's two
nothing there's power and speed by Quinton Byfield
that drives it right through the crease what an
effort by Quinton Byfield picks up all kinds of
speed in the neutral zone and he has one thought
he's dropping that shoulder bringing the puck to
the net and he makes no mistake about it we just
talked about the breakout season that Quinton
Byfield is have Dy he'll pick it up send it to
Center brunstrom nice nice little move sets up
Dubois Dubois brunstrom little give go larier
following up you heard brenon Gallagher talk to
AR Kenzie lone in the intermission about trying
to break through on this King steas slowski
does break in steals the puck and BR Suzuki off
the post as he gets his feet moving and brings
this Puck Around the Net it's a bobbling puck
for Kevin F he's not able to handle it and good
on your ice lvovsky for putting pressure on him
and nuk Nick Suzuki Suzuki looks coffields
way back to Suzuki Suzuki Coffield side of
the net and he scored from there before fiala
Kopitar back to fiala up for doie look ke way
goes back to fala we Rister tis out of the
Net score kind of a broken play and buried
for a second of the game quiton Byfield a power
play goal it's three nothing La it just throws
everyone off and as the shot comes through an
Kopitar is just going to direct this into an
area where Quint Byfield has made his way to the
back door no chance for Sam montmo but it's the
broken stick that throws everyone off if that
stick doesn't break that's a shot on net that
monteno it would have to be with three Hughes
in the lineup just a flurry of offense and no
Hughes goalies in that game mat the steel in
shoots into the glove jumps into the air of
a high flip opportunity from an Kopitar and
he tries to go on the far side low glove and
cam talit snags that one gulie jams it back
in Dy below the goal line Baron hustles over
sweeps at it then he gets tripped up by
the linesman and look out more in shoot
score Trevor Moore off the Breakaway buries
it his team leading 13th it's four nothing
La it was Justin bar who caught an edge
near the linesman here gets Tangled Up
with the linesman that opens up a lane for
Trevor Mo and he just quick release right
over the glove of Samuel montmo almost
looks like Justin Baron catches an edge
there Jake Evans in his own Zone under some
duress from Moore rra TR right in front say
Den still loose and it's more jamming
away monteo lost it found it lost his
stick does a nice job slid in across to
prevent that from happening Phil Doo is
involved in the play as well in the crease
and it's a jam play by fella montmo reads
that it's coming across he does a nice job to
stay with it on the backand of Trevor Moore
and small mistakes ended up costing them
a historic start to the season for the Los
Angeles Kings a new NHL record 11 straight
road wins to start the season and cam Tet